[Music]
dapper is always the first time we
talked you just got cast upon has Han
Solo we were standing on that was me you
know I just like to remind people where
they okay so whenever you're doing a
film like this which at you shot yes
it's real war it's real experiences what
is something that you learned that you
didn't previously know when making this
I think one of the big takeaways I
learned is that unless you actually live
the actual thing you kind of have no
idea the element of actually having
somebody trying to kill you is not
something I think any of us can actually
wrap our heads around what that's really
like and just to and from knowing that a
deeper sense of gratitude for the people
who put themselves in those situations
[Music]
great can I just say just bow down I
thought you were so great yeah thanks a
lot
now I remember interviewing rosamma for
rogue one and he said he had no idea
that the freighter was gonna be in the
movie when did you find out that spoiler
right what's gonna be there uh late like
when we were going back and picking
doing a few pickups there was a part in
the script where it said somebody
appears and it wouldn't say who and so
there was a lot of speculation amongst
the crew and cast about who is that
gonna be and then I found out like you
know a few months ago okay so you went
you went as pretty late yeah yeah we
were everyone was kind of talking about
in speculating and people there's some
people who really convinced I forget all
there are a lot of rumors yeah I thought
it was Palpatine for like a hot second
and then I was like wait a minute that's
Sam Webber's voice I don't know what
right right right yeah do you think
there's a there's a space for a han and
ma UL showdown at some point future film
maybe yeah that'd be pretty cool
right now solar rays I would say as many
questions as it answered but one of the
questions that answered which was super
fascinating for until his last name it's
not so right when did you find that out
what was your reaction when you read it
and what questions did you have when I
read the script I found it out and I
thought that was a really cool way that
they did that and and that you know that
it was a really kind of inventive and
fun way to put that together I thought
it was so cool because there were so
many things that it answered that I was
like huh like the Kessel run just
assumed it was a race there was a lot of
questions what is something whether it
be a new character that was introduced
or some kind of plot point that you'd
like to see explore it in the future I
think all the relationships between me
and Lando between me and Kira all those
relationships are so are so dynamic and
fun and interesting I'd love to see how
those play out are you coming back can
you tell I don't know we don't know I
think my pitch is a trilogy solo Lando
Maul just take that back to Pablo yes